there was a lot of machine-gun fire like
artillery firing down on us
first I was afraid and then I was numb I
didn't care what happened to me
I just do my job 19 you were ready to
die for your country that's right this
is my first time back to Normandy Beach
since the war since the war what do you
hope to accomplish on this trip what do
you hope to see the most well I want to
look back over the beach see a calm sea
you know boys just be a calm serene
place
my name is Rishi Sharma and I'm here in
Normandy to try to meet an interview
every single World War two combat
veteran of the Allied countries I've
been to 45 states in the US I've
interviewed just over a thousand
veterans so far and I think travel is so
fundamental to understanding the world
around you to understand history you
need to interact with the people who
were there put yourself in that position
you're boxed up in there and that whole
thing that's guarding it drops down low
it's just starting to fly in there how
would you feel I don't think I could
survive that
I was injured there or his little boat
all them so during the invasion you
basically took over as the [ __ ] and you
were the driver of the seconds boat huge
we had to go in drop the load back off
the beach to get back to skip get
another load
getting along there didn't have them
survive every single day of these heroes
lives it's been about other people and
the only way we can learn from them is
by talking to them I daresay you look
better now than you did back then you
talk to me about what's going on in your
mind what's it like to be back it's a
very distinct difference so nice serene
wide compared to the noise and confusion
75 years ago
I think what the best thing we can do
this what we're doing here today come
view where they're buried think about
their families and have an annual event
just like we're having now but don't
wait to the 75th or 80th or something
like that celebrate it every day save
what we have given you
you
[Music]